too much wine that's some morning
i left my baby while i'm at home and i'm
sitting here with my side [ __ ] riding
tonight yeah it's my birthday
for my love
cheers to the birthday queen and the
queen of pop
[Music]
madonna celebrates her 64th birthday
with an italian getaway where she's
living her best life it feels good
the material girl who turns 64 on
tuesday is sharing clips from her trips
italy on instagram check out madonna
getting ready for the night twirling
away
[Music]
from having a toast with friends to that
tongue kiss where she locks lips with
two gal pals too much
i love my baby mama at home and i'm
sitting here with my side [ __ ] he's
riding
madonna doubles down on her cheekiness
of course with this caption quote
birthday kisses with maasai [ __ ]
this isn't the only fun madonna is
having in italy
[Music]
the mom of six also shares snaps from
her time in sicily happy birthday
to me
which includes an extravagant dinner
full of her loved ones on the line
and she's clearly not too shy to show
off her musical skills
[Music]
madonna also gives fans a rare peek of
her son rocco who turned 22 last week
just four days before madonna's birthday
and here's a shot of rocko along with
his little sisters esther and stella who
turned 10 later this month that was a
fun moment for them when madonna isn't
busy being a mom and getting some
well-deserved r and r
she's handling business
i am making a movie about my life so
madonna's working on her highly
anticipated biopic easy spoke with her
pal debbie mazar in may after
speculation over who will play the pop
star so i don't know who madonna's gonna
cast but madonna is a very talented
she's very detail-specific and
i think that she'll choose the right
person i'm really proud of madonna for
you know doing this to write it because
i think she's got a great legend a great
story and fast forward to june et
confirmed julia garner is the top choice
for the pop legends role
julia played coy about it on watch what
happens live with andy cohen back in
february
there have been rumors that you are
going to be in the running for madonna's
biopic
can you spill the tea if you're being
considered i mean as i sit here and look
at you
i see it i see it i'm looking at the
album cover
for the first album
uh
you know
you
you know as much as i do well i do know
that she follows you on instagram and
that ain't easy to come by
wow
[Music]